HIS GOAL        ♪ ♪
THE ENTERTAINER AT THE LAST YEAR
WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENTS
DINNER, DITCHING THE TRADITIONAL
COMEDIAN AND BOOKING HISTORIAN
RON TURN NOW AS NEXT YEAR'S
FEATURED SPEAKER.
HE TWEETED "THE W ACA ARE
COWARDS, THE MEDIA IS COMPLICIT
AND I COULD BE PROUDER.
FOLLOWING THE GUBERNATORIAL
CAMPAIGN IN GEORGIA, SEVERAL
HOLLYWOOD ACTORS ARE ACTING FOR
A BOYCOTT IN THE FILM AND
TELEVISION INDUSTRY.
HERE WITH REACTION, AUTHOR OF
THE BRAND-NEW BOOK AMERICAN
ENTREPRENEUR, HOW 400 YEARS OF
RISK TAKERS, INNOVATORS AND
BUSINESS VISIONARIES BUILT THE
USA.
DOC AND BUCK COMMANDER AND A
CEO, THE MAN HIMSELF, WILLIE
ROBERTS.
YOU ARE GETTING A LITTLE MORE
GRAY AND THAT BEARD.
>> COME ON NOW.
YOU'RE LOOKING MORE SILVER AS
WELL MY FRIEND.
AND DAN BONGINO, FORMER
SECRET SERVICE OFFICER AND
"SPYGATE IS HIS NEXT BOOK.
YOU GUYS HAVE THIS HIT SHOW THAT
GOES ON FOR YEARS AND YEARS AND
YEARS.
YOU ACTUALLY MENTION GOD IN A
POSITIVE WAY.
AND YOUR DAD WANTED TO BAPTIZE
ME IN AN ALLOCATED           ALL
ME IN AN ALLOCATED           ALG
ME IN AN ALLOCATED           ALT
ME IN AN ALLOCATED           ALR
ME IN AN ALLOCATED           ALP
ME IN AN ALLOCATED           ALO
ME IN AN ALLOCATED           AL.
>> HE STILL DOES.
>> Sean: WHAT?
I'VE SEEN EPISODES WHERE THE
ALLIGATORS LIVE, AND HE WANTED
TO TAKE ME OUT THERE AND DUMP M
ME.
>> YOU KNOW OUR FAMILY IS STRONG
ABOUT OUR FAITH.
WE ARE WILLING TO SHOW THAT AND
NEVER HELD BACK FROM THAT.
YOU KNOW, I THINK ALL THAT
BOYCOTTING WOULD WORK, AND IT'S
GETTING OLD AND MY OPINION.
I THINK WE HAVE TO DEAL WITH THE
RESULTS AND SAY, LET'S MOVE ON
AND BE POSITIVE.
IF NOT, WE WILL HAVE TO HAVE ALL
NEW ENTERTAINMENT WITH THE LEFT
SIDE AND THE RIGHT SIDE.
COMEDIANS ARE SUPPOSED TO BE
FUNNY, BE FUNNY FOR ALL OF US.
>> I THINK A LOT OF IT, WE ARE
WATCHING A LOT OF SORE LOSERRIS
LOSERRISM, DAN BONGINO.
52 HOUSE SEATS, HE LOST IN HIS
FIRST MIDTERM, EIGHT SENATE
SEATS.
THEN YOU HAVE THE REAL WINNER,
HE LOSES SIX SENATE SEATS AND 63
HOUSE SEATS AND THAT'S
BARACK OBAMA'S FIRST MIDTERM.
JOHN PICKS UP ALL THE SENATE
SEATS AND ONLY LOST 37 HOUSE
SEATS WHICH BY THE WAY
HISTORICALLY ONLY HAPPENED, AND
THEY CAN'T HANDLE THE LOSS.
TRUMP OUTWORKED THEM AGAIN.
>> WHEREVER HE CAMPAIGNED FOR
THE SENATE SHEET, I CAN SEE IT,
THEY DID REALLY WELL.
BUT THINK ABOUT HOW SILLY AND
RIDICULOUS THIS ENTERTAINMENT
INDUSTRY FULL BOYCOTT OF
GEORGE'S IS.
THEY WORK IN A STATE LARGELY IN
CALIFORNIA, THE STATE OF GEORGIA
IS MORE BUSINESS FRIENDLY, WHICH
MAKES THEM MORE MONEY.
THIS IS STACY ABRAMS AND SHE DID
PRETTY WELL FOR GEORGIA.
AND THEY LIVE IN INTELLECTUAL
BLACK HOLE.
>> THEY ARE ALL INVESTING IN
CONTENT.
IT IS MASSIVE AMOUNTS OF MONEY
AND WHAT WE ARE FINDING IS,
FAMILY-FRIENDLY, GOOD THEMES
UPLIFTING MOVIES THAT HAVE A
MESSAGE AND AREN'T AFRAID TO SAY
THEY BELIEVE IN GOD, LIKE I DO,
AND YOU DO, THEY ARE DOING WELL.
BECAUSE THERE IS NO DOUBT THAT
PG MOVIES AND MOVIES THAT MORE
PEOPLE CAN WATCH ARE MORE
PROFITABLE, I'VE BEEN TO GEORGIA
AND I'VE SEEN THE NEW STUDIOS
AND IT'S UNBELIEVABLE WHAT THEY
ARE INVESTING DOWN THERE.
AND SO, IT'S GOING TO BE A LOSS.
THESE BOYCOTTS HAVE BEEN TRIED
BEFORE, SPEAKING OF GEORGIA, AND
YEARS AGO THE BOYCOTT FOR A
CHICK-FIL-A, THEY WERE BOYCOTTED
AGAINST.
AND THOSE THINGS FAILED.
>> Sean: I DON'T SUPPORT
BOYCOTTS.
THEY ARE JUST A WAY OF SHUTTING
DOWN AND SILENCING PEOPLE THAT
YOU DON'T AGREE WITH AND DAN
BONGINO, YOU KNOW THIS AS WELL
AS ANYBODY.
>> IT'S ALMOST THE GREATEST
THING THAT CAN HAPPEN TO YOUR
BUSINESS, HAVE THESE SILLY
LIBERAL GROUPS BOYCOTT YOU.
I WENT TO GET A CHICK-FIL-A
SANDWICH FOR THE BOYCOTT AND THE
LINE WAS UP THROUGH FREDERICK.
IT WAS THE DUMBEST BOYCOTT EVER.
>> WE CAN AGREE ON THAT.
>> BY THE WAY, CRACKER BARREL IS
ONE OF THEM.
AND WE ARE STILL DOING WHAT WE
DO.
SIT AROUND, EAT A LOT, PRAY AND